"Why You Should Be Grateful Everyday" by
Lazolia Buzuzi
For centuries cultures around the world
have linked the mind-body connection
with mental well-being and spiritual
insight. It's often associated with
religious practices and emotional
healing. Eastern societies have dominated
a holistic approach to maintaining
internal balance and psychological
health.
However we seem to have lost these
aspects of earlier human tradition in
our fast-paced modern Western
civilization. Mental disorders in the
United States and Canada are treated by
quick fixes. Be it prescription SSRIs
labels that excuse irrational behavior
or passive therapies. These aren't
necessarily bad without a doubt. Millions
of people have benefited from scientific
research and breakthroughs.
Psychological study however focusing
solely on the technical aspects of
mental illness has ended up ignoring
important details of the human being
that lies within the self simple
practices like mindfulness, positive
affirmations, and meditative thought are
believed to promote resilience and
reduce negative mentality. Lately there's
been an increase in empirical scientific
evidence to back this up. Take gratitude,
for example. Expressing and feeling
gratitude towards someone or something
external has been shown to have
interpersonal benefits. In 2003 Emmons
and Mccullough were the first to study
the effects of counting blessings on
mental health. Adult participants were
randomly assigned tasks where they had
to record on a daily or weekly basis
their hassles, expressions of gratitude
or neutral affairs. At the end of the
study period, there was a correlation
between the group that expressed
gratitude and the heightened sense of
mental and physical well-being
that recorded their blessings on a
regular basis reported a more positive
outlook on their livelihoods as well as
decreased physical symptoms and coping
behaviors unlike the hassle listing and
neutral groups.
A few years later the same experiment
was done by Fro at all on school-aged
children.
The results were parallel to their adult
counterparts the group of young
adolescent children that recorded their
blessings on a regular basis were more
optimistic and satisfied with their
lives in comparison to the students who
reflected on their day to day hassles or
neutral events. The results of the study
were particularly exciting not only
because they warded off mental ailment
symptoms, but because they showed a
relation between students gratitude and
improved satisfaction with their school
experience. A possible link between
gratitude and increased academic
performance. Although the results of
these studies are favorable showing the
profound advantages of routinely
expressing gratitude even over the
period of a few weeks, gratitude is a
rather difficult term to define.
Especially when it comes to identifying
how it benefits mental health gratitude
has been identified as an emotion
habitual act and a virtue of morality.
Among other things one must remember too
that simply talking or writing about
gratitude is not necessarily the same as
feeling it or actively practicing it.
Even so when one reflects on the
positive aspects of their lives, they
experience an improved mood pro-social
behavior and a heightened status of
their mental well-being
to illustrate this think of the fact
that for over 2,500 years Buddhist
teachings have concentrated on treating
mental instability among Eastern culture
and have helped to find states of mental
well-being to optimal functioning using
strategies like regularly expressing
gratitude and mindfulness mental
disorders although complex conditions
involving factors that contribute to the
development of symptoms can be addressed
effectively by changing small daily
habits that tackle one's mind brain body
and spirit by working on these aspects
of one's being an individual seeking
assistance may improve the quality of
his life psychological disorders can be
effectively treated if knowledge from
generations of Eastern based traditions
are incorporated into Western scientific
study. So what are you waiting for it.
Counting your blessings today and every
other day is sure to benefit your
overall health.
Comment below to tell us how
you've done so and what benefits you've
experienced doing so.